being a new mom is a test of resilience
but caroline has had another perhaps
greater challenge to me to me to feel as
though to exercise your sort of rights
in the workplace you had to take on the
power of the whole country
it just seems ridiculous Caroline claims
that she was forced from her job as a
firefighter after being diagnosed with
epilepsy she was based at RAF Croton in
Northamptonshire an airbase run by the
United States when I submitted my claim
to the employment tribunal they never
submitted any response just that UK law
didn't apply because they were enjoying
state immunity was the phrase that they
used that means that on this base even
though it's in the UK Britain's courts
have no jurisdiction over what the US
does it's the same US intelligence
station that American and sakuni's had
been driving out of when she was
involved in a fatal collision with
teenager Harry Dunne she claimed
diplomatic immunity and returned to the
u.s. meaning she too avoided the
oversight of British law at the heart of
this is the principle of whether anyone
is accountable for what happens on this
patch of British soil
it's the scenario also faced by the
family of Harry Dunne who are themselves
fighting for justice Harry's parents and
their lawyers don't believe answer Kunis
was ever entitled to immunity one of the
important issues arising from both the
Harry Dunn case and this one is that
there are a number of US military bases
in the UK or they are UK military bases
that are being run by the United States
and in and around those bases UK law
does not apply and there are hundreds of
staff working
who effectively operate in a impunity
and to the local laws there has been no
comment from either government the
Foreign Office has said they would not
want to prejudice any future appeal
Lisa Dowd Sky News Northamptonshire